mr horton
timothy can i call you tim mccoy also
the camera is held by one leo
tipton uh if you don't know we're up in
canada filming the edge of sleep
you could say hi if you want hello
all right she's not british horton
herder who the [ __ ] do you think you are
there are rumors that canadians really
love you
and your food i am unsure about that
coming from the good old country of
america
we pride ourselves in our fast food and
i think tim hortons is supposed to be
fast food but i've always known it to be
you know donuts and coffee that's what i
thought it was when i heard you had a
full menu
with like food i knew that i had to put
my expert reviewing senses to the test
and test your food with my expert
reviewing senses
it is so hot i'm sweating i was doing an
experiment i'm wearing many layers of
clothing
i'm doing an experiment where i'm seeing
what happens if i
stay hot all the time the results may
just be that i sweat a lot
it wasn't for a video or anything so you
don't need to know about this uh i'm
just gonna go get tim hortons so we're
gonna be back when we're in the
drive-through okay
all right cool all right see you in a
bit all right later i'll catch you later
all right have a good one yeah see you
around the bed i got to focus on the
road
all right i'll see you around hey we'll
catch up soon all right
catch you later all right see you soon
buddy all right pal
hey until next time see you around the
bend
catch you on the flip
you can cut anytime
um we're turning into tim hortons right
now uh we're in kamloops
which is this beautiful little town like
really beautiful town
um nestled kind of in these mountains
like it's a valley
um tim horton's just a [ __ ]
good color combination i shouldn't be
that biased elixie and replace
everything i just said with nice things
so we're pulling in here it's not too
busy i think traditionally
if i had to compare this to something i
would say would probably be close to
dunkin donuts but i'm not 100 sure
because i've never been to tim hortons
before but i'm going in with a lot of
assumptions
and i'm going to really put it to the
test barbecue pork barbecue
hi i'm so sorry it's going to be a quite
a large order is that all right
yeah okay so i'm going to start with an
assortment of donuts what would that say
uh an assortment of donuts like a
six-pack okay
uh yeah many things um could i get some
tim bits
a ten pack of those uh could i try
a uh a bacon club sandwich there was a
turkey cup sandwich
yeah turkey bacon club a chipotle
cheddar chicken
is that crispy or grilled grilled
yep anything else a bacon grilled cheese
melt
yeah anything else did i see something
about pulled pork
yep could i get one of those anything
else uh a bowl of chili okay
anything else yes um an english muffin
bacon or sausage sausage please sausage
english muffin yeah
and then a large cold brew vanilla cream
we actually don't have any cold brew
would you like a ice pack give me
whatever the fanciest coffee you have is
okay soft caramel ice cream is so large
anything else for you today and one hash
brown and one parchment
and one regular coffee left side
medium okay anything else for you today
that will be it
okay that'll be 49.05 at the window
thank you okay first thing
very nice memory incredible addiction
astonishing uh also price that was under
fifty dollars everything i ordered was
under fifty dollars that does not seem
right
i gotta put my mask on where's my mask
i don't know why i'm gonna hurry it's
not like they're gonna have my food
there
okay so i imagine it's gonna be a bit
but they seem pretty confident
they're assembling this order like crazy
fast i'm very impressed by this
thank you so much
thank you
that looks good
that looks so good holy [ __ ] smells good
what the hell good thing i said all
those nice things about this
before we came into here this is pretty
impressive hey
that's not coveted safe
yeah well it was mine
what do you have to say for yourself
it's hot
why is it it's iced woof
i'm so sorry thank you of course yeah
as i suspected delayed you know they're
just not timely it's the thing
they just like bad time management
probably this entire
infrastructure is corrupt from the
inside out is what i think it is
look at that wow that chocolate frosting
actually looks
very nice thank you
thank you is that everything okay
perfect thank you
okay so that was a lot of food under 50
and they got that out pretty quickly
they they got that out faster than i've
had
just a single sandwich come out from a
restaurant before
this seems dangerous a lot of things i
do seem different
cut out everything cut out everything
can you you know how you made an
artist's rendition of eve
can you make an artist rendition of leo
please
put it on a wanted poster as well
all right i'll see you when we get back
home all right bye okay good
all right cut
cut cut it now
this is when you would you know i don't
know when you're being serious
i'm always serious
[Applause]
oh the soup
could have done that a lot better and i
would have more of this but leo drank
this much
while in the car so
what the hell anyway so we have our
assortment of food here
there's breakfast items in here if you
call donuts breakfast items but there's
definitely a breakfast sandwich here
there's a i believe this is the pulled
pork there's a
bun
this is like leo's worst fear because
she's gluten-free
and so i couldn't even go near this
she'd puff up like a balloon and explode
um got a hash brown isn't that how it
works
okay cool that's what i thought um i got
chili
i got the sandwiches uh hash brown goes
in the hash brown holder
i don't know what that is i don't know
what that is i got butter
which is strange for the bread
why is your bread it's for the chili
okay it's really chilly i don't know
about that but maybe
okay so i'm gonna go in this
chronologically from the order how's my
hair it's my hair okay
keep rolling get some like inserts or
something
you got it keep it up
it's just kind of a test to see what she
does i have no idea
okay did you get it all right cool
how's my hair good it's good hairy
so i'm gonna start this chronologically
i'm gonna go in order of
what i would normally eat a meal or many
meals throughout the day i'm gonna start
with breakfast i'm gonna go to
second breakfast i'm gonna go to brunch
lunch uh
linner dinner and then dessert which i
think i'm gonna save for this
so the great thing about a dessert is
it's kind of the same as breakfast
depending on where you are in the world
donuts are kind of the staple of
breakfast even though they have very
little nutritional value and there's
really no purpose for it it's like
cereal
you know cereal is not a very nutritious
meal and yet when i was a kid
i'll be eating like cinnamon toast
crunch froot loops
uh trix like count chocula oreo o's
all of these have like no nutritional
value they are
dusted with vitamins and people expect
that to believe that they are going to
be
healthy because of that no if you're
going to eat a donut admit that you're
eating a donut because it's delicious
and full of sugar
don't pretend like it's healthy cereal
pretends donuts are honest
sharing with chocolate
i did not expect to be caught off guard
by that donut
it's a lot denser than what i would have
expected from a donut
when i have like dunkin donuts and stuff
like that it's very light
it's very uh fluffy that actually has
some substance to it
i'm not saying i dislike it i just was
not expecting it
and when it comes to my donuts you know
uh heftiness doesn't really ring
doesn't really spring to mine i'm gonna
whoa it's like a cinnamon roll but a
donut
i'm making a mess it's like a cinnamon
roll but a donut
that's not as good as i thought it'd be
but it's okay
and that's okay
flavor's coming back around and it's
gone that was okay
maybe it's because it's later in the
afternoon and they made all this in the
morning and it's not exactly fresh
i'm guessing that's exactly why this
isn't at its peak
however i am not overwhelmed by any of
this
i'm really underwhelmed i would be
overwhelmed
if it was amazing i'm right in the
whelmed area
donuts are very special donuts are
lovely
and and it's not like these are bad
donuts
much like pizza you know if you get a
donut it's gonna be okay but at the same
time
i'm not whelmed anyway let's try the tin
bits
these could just be the centers of those
you know
donut holes they call them tin bits
because
mr horton felt like it
other toons are you saying these are tim
horton's testicles
is that what you're saying
we here at markiplier hq have a very
high brow sense of humor
we elevate our jokes we don't go for
love blows like that
no matter how true it may seem you watch
yourself
okay um it's a hole right pretty okay
i'm not overwhelmed by any of this so
far as far as like what i thought
when i thought about tim hortons was
like donuts and coffee
and i know that i haven't had a chance
to try their coffee yet because i didn't
order coffee
but i'm gonna try this whatever this was
lixian insert the name of whatever this
was here
would you like caramel deliciousness
that someone else drank
[Music]
this is 600 unnecessary calories in the
first thing in the morning
if this is how you take your coffee
you're gonna have a lot of problems
later in life but god damn that's good
that is so much sugar but it's good
like wow um
that is sweeter than something that's
very sweet
like see an insert something that's very
sweet right here
maybe amy as for on the unlike a scale
of one to diabetes this is way up there
but delicious delicious
very good i used to when i was going to
college i would go to mcdonald's i would
get like a mcfrat pay or whatever it was
because they put nick in front of
everything i don't know why tim doesn't
pretend from anything
tim's bits he did tim donuts tim nuts
tim nuts they're like tim horton's
testicles
lexian roll the laugh track
breakfast salmon
this is pulled pork breakfast sandwich
this
i actually is my staple one but
mcdonald's
uh sausage and egg mcmuffin is what i
always get whenever i go for a
mcdonald's breakfast i don't deviate
from it if they
ha i'll sometimes spice it up i'll get
like a packet of hot salsa which some
people don't know the mcdonald's has
they have packets of hot sauce all the
time
and uh this one is kind of similar to
that
so i'm going to compare it directly to
that no matter how unfair that i seem
very good slightly less salt than
mcdonald's uses i think
they butter their muffin that's obvious
the sausage is good the cheese is melty
the egg is very nice but there's
something about it that isn't gluing it
all together for me
like all the pieces are there all the
ingredients are there
but it's really just not coming together
in the way that i would imagine that it
would
you know what i mean like that's kind of
the staple of everything that i've
tasted so far
maybe it's just a canadian thing like
canadian palette is slightly different
and i'm not used to that
but it's really not all coming together
like i would
want it to it's good don't get me wrong
it's not bad but when comparing it to
like the
experience that i get when i say go to
mcdonald's or something or even like
dunkin donuts has a similar breakfast
sandwich not quite the same
but this one just isn't zinging in my
mouth
by the way i'm gonna eat all this i'm
just gonna be eating tim hortons for a
while i don't want to waste some food
eve you know the [ __ ] eve gave me for
even the thought that i would waste
maples here you know how much
she gave me it was a lot it was a lot
a lot but don't worry i donated the
maple syrup to her and she's going to be
making
tons of granola now we're moving on to
lunch and i actually do
when i go good call
good call you're getting a raise
i don't pay you i'm sorry
[Music]
i would rather think that the employee
at tim hortons took a bite out of this
then to know that the moment i turned my
back you took a bite of my hash brown
it's a hash brown it's good then again
the criteria for hashbrowns being good
is very light it's potato and oil and
salt you're not going to get much more
than that
it's got a nice brown to it i like it
crispier i like burnt things
it could be a little more burnt in my
opinion but it's okay
very good
did you just eat the paper
this is done what is this i think this
is the wrap
oh oh i love the presentation
i really like the presentation of this
this is dope
get a close-up get at the detail detail
shot
look at the striations here look at that
that is a good pattern aesthetics are
everything when it comes to food
the look of food oh look at that the
green sticking out
that is good i don't care if it's just
an illusion and like they print the
tortillas like this
this looks good this looks appetizing i
want to eat this
okay
all right tim you have my attention i
will now allow you to sponsor me
for the low low price of only two
hundred thousand dollars per video
you can sponsor your very own markiplier
video just pay me all the money up front
put it right in my hand and i will save
tim hortons at the beginning of every
video until here until the end of time
no i'm just kidding you haven't wowed me
enough for that
i would eat more i will meet more of
that later i don't need to put it here
but like did i say enough about this did
i speak it's
it's chicken wrap with like chipotle
sauce whatever you don't care i'll eat
it later
very good though what is you what are
you
sandwich
hmm
sandwich
it's a sandwich how much intro do you
want for these
pieces of it looks like a sandwich bread
meat
no cheese bacon
crispy bread buttered
mayonnaise i know canadians love their
mayonnaise
you love mayonnaise i know that
i don't normally like tomato and things
but this works this will blt anyway
what more time i say this isn't like a
food eating channel it's a food review
channel and i'm not even reviewing food
it's not even a food review channel
this is about the tim horton's
experience this isn't about the
individual taste
i'm talking about the complete
experience of tim hortons i'm trying to
get everything
of a lifetime of tim horton's into one
video that's what i'm condensing here
i'm imagining i'm out in the
wilderness of saskatchewan does
saskatchewan have wilderness
the wilderness of british columbia which
is where i am right now i'm out in the
woods
living off the land all i have is an ax
a dog a cabin
and tim hortons
it's good my well-dominator
is starting to tick up over into
overwhelmed territory but it's still in
the middle of whelmed
slightly below the midpoint this is
underwhelmed this is wound this is
overwhelmed
so it's it's about right here okay all
right now this is a melt
now when i was in college i would
make melts all the time because i
actually had a meal plan and i could
afford to eat
and that was that was good times i liked
that and then i didn't get a
meal plan for later so i made melts
every day and i
i really enjoyed them smell is very
important to food
smell your food before you eat it it's
not weird that you do
like the video if you smell your food
before you eat it if you don't smell
your food before you eat it
like the video that is a very good
grilled cheese i forgot what this was
it's not a melt it's grilled cheese
but one thing that they did well that
they did well in the wrap is like this
grill pattern it looks good it looks
appealing but also
if you notice there's cheese not only on
the inside which i believe is either
american or cheddar it doesn't really
matter
cheese bacon but there's cheese on the
outside as well
i don't know what kind of cheese but it
adds a little the experience it's not as
good to hold like it's not pleasant to
hold because it's just very greasy
and it feels like it's sticking to my
fingers but as far as taste goes
this is really well done really tim
hortons in terms of sandwiches
i've never had better sandwiches at a
fast food place i'm not talking like
burgers
i'm talking like traditional like
sandwiches the wrap the blt
the grilled cheese sandwich i'm gonna
actually dip this in my chili
if i'd i would have tomato soup if i do
this normally but you know chili works
two thumbs up i will review the chili
next but this is quite good
tim i don't know how you canadians do it
up here
i don't know how you eat chili what kind
of barbarian eats chili with a knife and
a fork
i really needed a spoon here my
wellmedometer was really spiking up with
that grilled cheese
it is now dipping below about a third
okay
there is so little that i could forgive
when it comes to chili experience what
am i going to do
when the liquid just drips right through
my fork
what what about the bread
what oh this is my spoon is this my
spoon
am i spooning with this didn't know it
was a
arts and craft adventure whittle my own
spoon out of bread
it's like a bread bowl but bread spoon
ah that's a good idea
but i'm not assuming that you had that
intention from the get-go i think you
just forgot the spoon
and given that every employee and every
establishment represents
the command structure from top to bottom
it was like you didn't give me a spoon
yourself
mr horton you're not allowed to sponsor
me anymore
i don't want your canadian dollars
they're no good
i take back everything i said
[Music]
you're lucky that chili's good god damn
the only other chili i could compare to
would be wendy's
and this is better there's no question
there's only one item left zoom
on me on me zoom on me and this is the
big one and now lixie and zoom even
further
this is the big one okay this is the
mama
this is the mama jamba this is the big
kahuna
keep it steady don't move leo
this is the big goon this is a mama
jamba
this one's for all the beans
and pan down
pulled pork i don't know why this is for
all the beans
but i think this is special because i've
literally never seen pulled pork
at a fast food place ever is there
cheese on this oh
that's interesting i don't know how
that's gonna be but there seems to be
cheese on this
ordinarily i would have this drowning in
barbecue sauce but right now there's
cheese
and like some barbecue sauce there's a
little bit leaking around the edges here
i really have no idea what to expect
going into this but let's give it a try
[Music]
this would be great this would be great
if i had a tub of barbecue sauce to dip
it in
because it it's it's drier than the
sahara
it's so dry it's like
there's no sauce on this like i can
forgive that it's kind of cold because
obviously i
ordered it fast food i drove it here the
quality of the meat isn't too bad either
like this doesn't seem like they just
ran the pork machine until it just
turned out goo
you know this seems like actual meat um
but so dry it's a pulled pork sandwich
it needs to be
weeping sauce it needs to be gushing
sauce out of the burger
or the sandwich it needs to be rivers of
barbecue sauce
pouring down my hands that's pulled pork
there's gotta be so much sauce i don't
even know there's meat in there
this would be good this would be good my
weldometer all the way down
and we're back up the middle okay i'm
perfectly whelmed by this
i'm not amazed i'm not incredibly aided
but i am well i think it was a decent
experience there were some really
upsides to it the donuts were okay but
i'm not really a big donut guy anyway
like i don't go out of my way to eat
donuts
but they were kind of like when i bite
into them i'm willing to chalk that up
to a different taste palette
canadians with their weird mystical ways
that no one can understand
who knows what they're even thinking but
they have different ways the timbits
you know they were okay they're not bad
i like them
as far as any doughnut hole goes pretty
basic
the sandwich itself the breakfast
sandwich not very great
pretty okay i liked it um not as good as
what i would prefer from other places
sandwiches
however the wrap incredible fantastic
the grilled cheese stunning love that
blt
crisp delicious the chili
stunning great chili it's strange all
the foods that i i would not
normally go out of my way to a fast food
place or especially a drive-through
place to go really good stuff
however this was so disappointing pulled
pork excited me
it drew me in it tantalized me tempted
me it was seductive
i wanted it i wanted it bad you know oh
i wanted
and when i got it i was just left with
regret and sadness
disgusted with myself and what i had
done
oh the depravity
not enough sauce bread was good i guess
i'm so confused by it but it's there and
that's something other places wouldn't
do
free bread is cool at a restaurant
thanks for trying to class it up
question from the gallery i feel like
you judged the donuts a little assume
you didn't try every one
they're different flavors
this is where the bonus round of dessert
comes in i had a secret i was gonna i
was gonna do this whole thing because i
do in every video if you actually
watched my videos
in every review video i have a little
secret surprise at the end of it and
then i turn up
i didn't have a surprise at the end of
this one this is just this is your
surprise congratulations
this is what you get everybody basic
[Music]
frosted
[Music]
it's still like the dense doughiness of
the donut and i know a donut is called a
doughnut probably because of very doughy
like a pill bear doughboy
but it's still surprising it's it's very
chewy not bad the flavor is good the
like frosting i do like frosting is fine
this is actually that different type of
cake doughnut
sensor that one's fluffier
which is so weird because the normal
donuts like well normal donuts and
donuts in america it would be like those
bigger ones would be the lighter ones
and this would be the denser one but
this is fluffier than those
here's a cake doughnut chocolate
mixing the flavors a little bit i like
that better i like this better than the
other cake donuts that i've had before
frosted chocolate cake donut
oh that one's right
good advice why don't you ever dare
interrupt a review video ever again
never forget
um thank you everyone so much for
watching
don't worry i will eat all this
eventually i just will not eat it all
right now so no food is going to be
wasted i'm going to be eating well for
quite a few days here
and thank you everybody so much for
watching subscribe if you want to see
more i have more reviews
that i've done in the past if you have
not seen it or not familiar with my
review process my
extremely extremely impressive review
process
lincoln is in the
link is in the lexington point where it
is it's down there
go check out more videos that i made
thank you leo for helping out
you can check out leo on instagram link
is also in the description
where can they find your stuff i think
it's leo tipton okay
all right look for leotipton if not
there's a link in the description
down below go click that okay i will be
collating all of your comments
everything that you've said thus far
before ending the video and i will be
banning everyone that said
a comment before they got to the end of
the video because how dare you write a
comment before the end of the video
subscribe for more okay bye